hey everyone I'm Dave and what I have
for you today is a full 3v3 match
recorded in the dawn of war 3 beta I'm
playing as the space marines who have
teamed up with two teams of filthy xenos
orcs but if you enjoy the video make
sure you hit that like button and
subscribe for more videos just like this
one
tactical marines or three
let us stage an attack here servitor I
don't tempt you to his lowest point we
are ready for tactical marine Scott
deployed tactical squad I shall walk
scenes 2.4 bedient and facial scan
teachers and coordinates
shake you
ready
only received secure resources into
hiding brothers master
Space Marines ready
tactical Marines readying for top
we've completed a requisition generator
tactical squadron turkey into hiding
tactical Marines are in position to
commence deep strike
I silk see some resources Baron
employment
[Music]
this one says as punishment
come on
Chapel barracks destroy this is one is
underway
will you call forth our elite warriors
commander character tacticals
[Applause]
yes come on
[Applause]
don't drink chocolate rain
the power generator
[Applause]
efficiency logarithms compel this
servitor to request oh boy and one
follows his Lords instructions this one
does as ordered
winning
we've completed a power generator allure
nice one involved we are ready for war
[Music]
salt marine squad deployed
serve it all is equipped for
construction build routine seven
[Applause]
dr. Gillman
generator is ready
come on
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
this
reclining
affluence prepare to arm our warriors
ok
[Music]
let us make ourselves unseen preparing
slippers for deployment is complete
sniper scouts deployed
Oh
tactical marines ready
[Music]
assault marine squat deployed you will
tactical Marines ready bringing that my
drop party is available it shall be as
you command upgrade completed
I see something we dragging completed
and afraid
[Music]
[Music]
there's about two marks location we
should make this you have the trail
leads this way
point we will harness my lord moving
into cover now we're brass what is my
dogs captioning resource point this
battle has escalated to the second phase
hunt will make for a fine soldier what
are tacky kill it Sarge coincides with a
hunt I'll completed green slaughter
Oh
[Music]
New Year's out
this calculus hey Willard may this view
our victory generator enjoys an attack
our little buggers are ready to deploy
at your post is active
ready to jump come on barking
we must shield generator
happy potter team--amazing quizzes ideas
we saw provided brother
we've completed an early point generator
we completed a requisition generator as
one would comply happy Volta team
deployed from this upgrading infantry
damage vault is moving
dr. squad
[Music]
heavy bolter new firing position
brothers we win these excesses of
resource for him but must spend them
tactical marine radio duty
infantry damage upgrade secured
authority to use an attack
must attack decision
Paris is under fire
drop pod deployed
may not find us amazing this is
unleashing shall we the turret endures
an attack this day
usiness for us to say ready just the
roar of our salvo
let's count sharples of power use it
that boy what's the wheel is required
initiating machine cults deployment it
is my duty to abide the might of the
bloody else was with you
these Baltar's are our weapons we are
you social issues are best left to us
the stasis for deployments infantry
weaponry upgrade in progress preparing
us for Marines for deployment
I have the trail follow brothers and
cannon team deployed can form country
mile
Marines deployed machine George at the
ready
a requisition generator is ready
preparing whirlwind for deployment
different rear Everly is improved look
to our vulnerable listening post South
Marines ready to drop
ready
listening in the region a pro generator
is ready dreadnought deployed we've
operated in country home we have missile
submarines report ready to drop heading
out this dreadnaughts for is being CEO
these online c'mon fights which Raptor
answer heading out this one's function
is as follows we have little to spare I
am relocating whirlwind relocate the
torrent shockwave ability is retired
killed again eat yes dreadnought
readying for drop bearing tactical
Marines for deployment now your turn
we've completed an operational upgrade
completed
will let's talk tactical marine squat
deployed
God
tactical Marines were deployed yes
she's killed
we do with our surplus of requisition I
understood ready moving upgrading to
plasmin in death an edgy try not on
standby for orbital drop
readying plasma guns he who fights with
me
I am Gabriel I understand we win these
successes of resource for him but must
spend on
the orcs killed ourselves an elite King
tactical salon right
will ensure it
practical marine squad deploy
see
you call our elite warriors commander
under way
I thought Marines were deployed